America's Wild West
their predator and prey Clash head to
head in Epic Battles of survival but
what happens when America's most
ruthless killers and even its unlikely
aggressors turn on each other
[Music]
Animals by tooth and Claw against their
own kin
to win food territory and rights to the
bloodline
in the wild there are no rules this is
Alamo Fight Night
and over 2 000 pounds of solid muscle
the American Bison is Born to Fight
the violent blows and shock waves miles
through the Earth
welcome to the Thunderdome
[Music]
foreign
the end of a violent three-month running
season
bison on this Battleground a Rife with
deep wounds and broken ribs
this impressive 13 year old bull is the
Envy of the herd
it's caught the attention of an eager
female
wooing her with elaborate costumes and a
suggestive strut
but to make sure it's his genes that are
passed on this Casanova defends his
female from other eager mans
standing guard 24 7 doesn't leave much
time for grazing
the old bull has lost 200 pounds of his
body weight
is weak vulnerable
and the rest of the herd is taking
notice
an 11 year old is first to step up to
the plate
alongside the old Bull in what's called
a broadside threat
the scuffle is brief the 11 year old
realizes he's no match for the old bull
so he backs down
but a younger male is getting amped up
for a fight
the rebellious teen wallows in a pit of
dirt and his own urine
the old bull follows suit
the bigger the dust cloud the more
intimidating the Rival
[Music]
charges
two tons Collide at 40 miles an hour
foot long vertebrae anchor massive neck
muscles to create a driving force
and matted fur forms a three inch thick
helmet to cushion the hip
juvenile drives his rival across the
plains like a ragdoll
it looks like the old boy backs off but
it's a bluff
saved his strength until this moment
turn
then the old man pummels him from the
left
uses two thousand pounds of brute
strength to Ram the young Bull's rib
cage
foot horns stabbing him like bayonets
the juvenile's lungs are 13 times the
size of a human's and vulnerable to
puncture
[Music]
It's the final assault
the old bull has won
the juvenile has injured his leg in the
final hit he's now easy pickings for
predators
a tough lesson has been learned respect
your elders
from the massive
to the miniature
just underfoot two hundred thousand
pint-sized prairie dogs call this
grassland home
I may have taken urban sprawl to the
extreme
[Music]
several colonies make up a complex
tunnel system that spans the area of
Manhattan
it may look crowded but there are
advantages to City living
[Music]
more Lookouts
more alarm Bells
and more Playmates but as with any
close-knit family there are heated
disputes
one male for breeding females and their
offspring make up this prairie dog pack
and six new additions have just arrived
okay
this two-year-old female has just given
birth to her first litter
she's an overprotective mother and she
has good reason to be
fifty percent of newborn pups are killed
in the first few weeks of life
and a family member is often the Killer
lactating females kill and eat their
sister's infants
this ensures her own pups will have a
greater chance of survival
our young mom stands guard at the
borough entrance
her cannibal sister is on the prowl for
rival offspring
our young mom sponsor
the murderous flies into the borough
guns blazing
but our dogged mom keeps herself between
her pups and her killer sister
finally her sister Retreats and heads
above ground
but our mom follows her
beside the fighting escalates
our two-year-old is well armed with
incisors that never stop growing
and sharp claws primed for digging
fights like these can end in open wounds
and Tails bitten in half
at the heart of every good mom is a
fighter like a determined three pound
bodyguard she blocks the barrel
the sister makes a sneaky approach
she's blocked again
prairie dogs are the Kung Fu fighters of
the animal world
finally the young mom drives her sister
away
and takes up her guard post at the
tunnel entrance
three weeks later the pups have grown to
three times their size no longer
vulnerable to cannibalistic attacks
and they have their mom to thank for it
above ground a much larger and more
powerful container enters the ring
wild mustangs icons of the American West
they were the all-terrain vehicles of
Frontier Cowboys
for Generations later the high-tempered
beasts are anything obtained
there is a strict pecking order in Wild
Horse Society
foreign
ladder
be a dangerous game
[Music]
Nevada's Great Basin Desert
it's a rugged Wasteland where Only the
Strong Survive
it's heard of eight mares and they're
awesome find strength in numbers
seven-year-old male holds his post as
the protector of the group
Patrol for rogue stallions looking to
mate with his Mares
[Music]
he's equipped with an extraordinary
field of vision
he can see almost panoramically with
only a small blind spot between his eyes
and at his rear
a lining inside his nose is 100 times
larger and far more sensitive than our
own
while their outturned nostrils give them
stereo olfaction telling them which
direction a rogue stallion may be coming
from
[Music]
he detects a lone male approaching from
his left
it's not colored Intruder is old and
battle-worn
he's a social animal and he wants to
join this herd
[Music]
but the lead stallion won't make it easy
for him
the wind shifts and the herd leader
catches the old stallion's scent
he won't tolerate an intruder
balancing on two levels they start
throwing punches
at one thousand pounds the young
stallion has the weight Advantage but
desperation fuels the old man
the young stallion's 12 front incisors
meet evenly at the front perfectly
designed for ripping flesh and a
lifetime of chewing grass has given him
jaw muscles powerful enough to crush
muscle and Brake bone
thank you
neither horse can get a good bite so the
black and white stallion kicks it up a
notch
fires backward with a force of 2200
pounds
that's like twice the force of a
sledgehammer to the face but can't
connect
[Music]
exhausted the young stallion concedes
it's a decision that saves the old
stallion's life he gains the acceptance
of the herd but knows his place as
second in command
our next Contender has no arms and no
legs but he can fight like the best of
them
masters of camouflage
and Experts of the hunt the rattlesnake
is a force to be reckoned with
they measure the length of an adult
human from Fang to rattle
and can deliver Venom 19 times more
potent than rat poison
they can strike twice as fast as a human
can blink but what happens but it's
Rattler versus rattler
[Music]
hikers come across two male rattlesnakes
duking it out in competition for a
female that one makes quite a bit bigger
when you look at his head sizes the two
snakes could paralyze and kill each
other with their venom oh man
so they agree on one strict rule of
Engagement
no biting
you know
instead they try to pin the other to the
ground in what's called a combat dance a
Rattler's body is packed with 12 000
muscles 15 times more than a grown man
oh yeah throw down this means they can
twist in any direction with incredible
power
that it's estimated that 75 of the time
the heavier snake will win
but with these Rivals equally matched
the outcome is anyone's guess
one snake tries to take the advantage
but the other Bobs and weaves out of the
way
the snake that tires first will tap out
and take off
okay someone's upside down
with his white belly exposed the
overturned snake is now a prime target
for Predators flying overhead
he has just enough energy to wriggle out
of this headlock
in other Rattler wrestling matches the
outcome is more obvious Pride destroyed
and too exhausted to carry on the loser
will remain on the ground while the
winner rides above him in a victory
dance
the loser leads the ring
a champ make sure of it
where most animals of the American West
try to avoid fights bighorn sheep seem
to enjoy them
please
late November in the Rocky Mountains
and it's mating season
females will only welcome advances for
the next 15 days
now or never for these eager Cowboys
there's no time for Romance
with so many rivals fights are almost
always imminent
A Lone Ranger arrives from the East
he's a seven-year-old at the height of
puberty and it's the first year he's
playing The Mating Game
but it won't be easy
to pass on his genes he'll have to
become the dominant Brown
I have to fight his way to the top
he challenges this bachelor band one by
one
in these bar room brawls size strength
and stamina determine the winner
The Lone Ranger zeros in on an opponent
he's five years older and over 10 pounds
heavier
tests his Rivals manhood
with this not so gentle prodding
[Music]
The Lone Ranger challenges him to a
shootout it's an invitation the old Ram
just can't refuse at first it looks as
though they call a truce
but then like gunfighters of the Wild
West they turn
and Fire
heads Collide at 20 miles an hour an
impact that could kill a human instantly
are armed with a powerful weapon
weighing in at 30 pounds their horns are
heavier than all the bones in their body
combined
and nearly an inch of flexible keratin
prevents them from snapping during
combat
these collisions should knock out both
opponents but their skulls are
engineered to take the hit their
forehead is up to three times thicker
than a human's
and inside the skull a network of sinus
Chambers extends into the horns creating
a crumple Zone upon impact
and cradling the brain like a walnut in
its shell
but if the hit is hard enough the
contenders could die from severe head
trauma
The Lone Ranger moves uphill to gain the
advantage
a higher position
maximizes battering power
they could go on like this for over a
day
but the old bull just can't withstand
the crushing blows
you'll have to let this one go
Han Rams maybe the Quick Draw Cowboys of
the Wild West
but our next Contender is capable of
Waging full-scale War
they mobilize troops
they torture their victims and they
launch chemical attacks
ants have shock and awe down to a
science
but there's one ant species that uses
its military mind against its own kind
this is a polyergus ant
but she's better known as the
slave-making ant
her mandibles are so sharp that she
can't even feed herself
sickle-shaped mouth parts are designed
for a single purpose
murder
[Music]
it all starts innocent enough
female with a taste for power has no
chance of rising within her own colony
the queen won't tolerate rivals
so the slave making female leaves with
her unhatched eggs
start a family of her own
but instead of building an empire
steals one
her Target a colony of 600 formica
worker ants
she may be outnumbered but the slave
making princess has a trick up her
sleeve
gland called a doofer gland releases a
pheromone that pacifies the formica
workers
[Music]
the intoxicated Defenders lay down their
weapons and allow the slave maker to
pass
foreign
[Music]
now her mission is to assassinate the
formica Queen and steal her identity
The Colony Queen is caught off guard
she doesn't stand a chance against The
Intruders serrated daggers
after 20 minutes of torture
Throne Queen waits for the sweet release
of death
now this nightmare takes an even more
disturbing turn
the slave-making princess licks the
wounds of the Fallen Queen
taking on her scent
the formica workers surround the
Intruder they move their antennae over
the new Queen's body
feeling for hydrocarbons along her
abdomen identity markers that help
distinguish friend from foe
by covering herself in the spilled
fluids of her victim the Intruder has
convinced The Colony that she is and
always has been their Queen
600 formica ants are now her loyal
slaves they'll feed her clean her and
raise her polyergus brood
but as the workers die out the slave
making Queen must replenish her Army
[Music]
so she sends her entranced Minions on a
raid
nearly 2 000 ants on a military
operation to pillage and enslave
[Music]
the slave-making Raiders stream into the
formica nest
but it's not the soldiers that the Army
is after
their target
is the nursery
the kidnappers deal up to 600 unborn
formica Young
carrying each larva 130 feet back to
their polyergus nest it's like a human
walking 15 miles while carrying a piano
in three weeks these formica young will
be born into slavery ready for a life of
grooming feeding and protecting their
cruel slave making Queen
cold Sunrise across America's Great
Plains marks the peak of the breeding
season for sharp-tailed grouse
[Music]
this field sets the stage for males to
strut their stuff
there are 40 females here to impress and
only one or two males will get to mate
with them all first they'll have to
prove their word
on the dance floor
they are the lightweight Lords of the
dance stamping their feet a whopping 20
times a second as they spin in circles
and shake their tail feathers
they started please like wind-up toys
gone haywire and their choreography must
be Flawless having two left feet is not
an option but if a male can't outdo his
rival with his Ballroom skills he turns
to his battle skills
in the midst of these mating dances the
males square up and fight
their tactic is unique
draw the bright yellow flesh above each
other's eyes
the bigger and brighter this patch the
more attractive they are to females
so if this flashy calling card is
destroyed females will lose interest
these fights rarely end in death
but their eyes risk Serious injury
a frenzy of feathers the male on the
left misses the bullseye
finally he hits his Target
with his yellow eyebrow damaged the
sharp tail will have a hard time
attracting a mate
bruised and battered he's fighting a
losing battle
as quickly as it started the fight is
over
and the winner returns to the dance
floor
[Music]
is an animal that doesn't rely on fancy
footwork to win the fight
it's mating season for elk
and the males are not acted like
themselves
shortened daylight hours trigger a
biological surge in testosterone
their neck and hump swell to up to twice
their normal size and the Velvet on
their antlers peels off to expose deadly
spikes
nature is literally driving them to
fight
when Elko antler to antler the
contenders can be brutally stabbed or
even killed
this Rocky Mountain elk is king of his
harem
he sprays himself with his own Grand of
cologne it's called thrash urination and
it's a pungent signal of authority the
odor doesn't go unnoticed a yearling
bull responds by trashing vegetation
it's a call to battle
pass on his genes this yearling will
have to fight and win
they mirror each other in a sideways
strut
both are armed with 12 Jagged Spears as
strong as cast iron
at the core is a network of soft bone
designed to absorb the force of repeated
collisions and on the outside College
impact bone makes the antlers nearly
Unbreakable
the dominant bull gains the uphill
advantage
they both try to get around the other's
deadly headgear
antlers lock in a dangerous pushing
match
they could go on like this for hours
leaving behind them a path of
destruction
they're aiming for each other's legs and
body
for good reason
calcium and phosphorus are stripped from
the other bones in their body and used
to strengthen their antlered Weaponry
leaving their skeleton thinned weak and
susceptible to fracture
dominant male Powers the Young Buck down
the hill
snap neck
the dominant male drives off his
competitor in a final push
another large Buck nearby has been
injured in battle
he has fended off several lesser males
gunning for his harem
[Music]
but he can't let his guard down
another Challenger approaches
battle lines are drawn
the large male is limping and in pain
but the fight Must Go On
with a combined weight of 700 pounds
heavyweights Clash like linebackers at
the Super Bowl their antlers Tower four
feet above their heads
armed with 16 individual daggers
the Challenger takes a hard stab
the old bull digs deep
it's enough to scare off the Young Buck
but another Bachelor guns for his
females
all the old bull can do is issue a war
cry
damn
it works for now the old bull hangs on
to his harem
from the Rocky Mountains to Arizona's
Sonoran Desert he
one creature uses a more powerful weapon
than antlers to fight his own King
no animal packs a heavier punch than the
desert scorpion
like Medieval Nights they are covered in
a full suit of body armor with plier
like pincers and a venomous Barb
this four-year-old desert scorpion is
five inches of hard body shell
he rarely Strays farther than three and
a half feet from his burrow
and he doesn't have to as an
opportunistic Hunter this juvenile waits
for food to stray into his territory but
no insects have wandered past in months
and he's on the brink of starvation
hairs along his pincers are picking up
vibrations through the air
and comb-like sense organs have detected
unfamiliar pheromones
there's an intruder in his midst
a neighboring scorpion has stumbled into
his territory it's a mistake that could
cost him his life
scorpions are known to eat each other
driven by hunger a juvenile scorpion
fires in from the left attacking his
neighbor
they're evenly matched in size and
strength
it's a game of kill or be killed
[Music]
like any armored Knight each one is
equipped with a sword a scorpion is able
to concentrate Metals in its diet into
its stinger making it literally metal
plated and inside the Barb is Venom
potent enough to paralyze prey or
arrival
[Music]
the juvenile turns the Intruder onto his
back
our four-year-old finds a soft spot and
delivers a crushing blow
two glands in the Barb pump a cocktail
of neurotoxins into the neighbor's body
shutting down his nervous system once
paralyzed the Killer's digestive enzymes
begin to liquefy the victim's body
and the cannibal killer sucks out the
nutrients like a scorpion smoothie this
fight night has only one Victor and All
That Remains of the loser is his toxic
Tale
our next contenders may not have venom
in their Arsenal but they are expert
Killers nonetheless
wolves
30 pounds heavier than a German Shepherd
with fangs as long as a human thumb
take down prey much larger than
themselves
but what happens when wolves turn their
weapons on their own kind
one-on-one or pack versus pack Wolf
attacks are bloody and vicious
with the most powerful jaws of all
canines they puncture vital organs and
break bones
foreign
[Music]
Valley
Yellowstone's richest hunting ground
for wolves
several wolf packs surround Lamar and
like rival street gangs they fight for
the coveted territory
one wolf pack has held control of Lamar
for the past eight years
The Druids
in their Heyday the pack was 37 strong
but disease has left them with only nine
on the other side of the ridge the slew
Creek pack has grown to 15 outnumbering
The Druids
it's early morning and the sloughs are
making their move
they've been gunning for Lamar for years
and now the scales have tipped in their
favor
Druids take off to meet the threat
and the two packs come head to head at
the northern border of the valley
on territory boundaries that most wolf
on wolf killings occur
neither pack dares to cross
[Music]
es launch a second attack
and the pack fans out to show their
formidable size
The Druids are battling against the odds
at first there's confusion
but the slough Creek alpha male spots
his Target
his muscle packed body launches for the
Druid alpha male at 40 miles per hour
the slough Creek Alpha sinks his
two-inch canines into his rival's neck
trying to cut off his windpipe and
suffocate his victim
two more Slough Creek wolves gang up on
the Druid Alpha
one of the slews clamps down on the
druid's back with the force of 130
pounds if his bite injures his rival's
spinal cord the Druid Alpha could be
paralyzed this is Turf Warfare at its
most vicious but the alpha manages to
Break Free the Druid pack Retreats but
the sloughs are Relentless
at the top of the ridge the sloughs
continue to bite and tear
it's enough to push The Druids from the
valley for good
[Music]
there's only one animal that can give
the wolf a run for its money the largest
and most dangerous carnivore in the
continental U.S
tourists capture two large male
Grizzlies competing for the same female
what unfolds is a battle between this
fight club's most vicious contenders
beneath their skin blocks of muscle in
the hump and shoulders give them the
fighting strength of five grown men
a darker bear is the first to challenge
but it's a false charge
it's not enough to scare the lighter
bear
only four percent of these threat
displays escalate to full-on fights this
is one of the four percents
oh
these two male grizzly bears seem
equally matched in combat but the darker
male has the weight Advantage he's 100
pounds heavier and a foot longer
dominant males kill subordinates who get
in their way
their muscles tighten and hearts race as
highly oxygenated blood pumps to their
powerful legs and arms
tall
they are in a vicious Deadlock
prevents them from getting a good bite
[Music]
if they get in the right position one
could crush the other skull with one
bite
the lighter bear go gorilla jugular
he has exceptionally thick skin around
his neck to protect his carotid artery
the large male is equipped with two-inch
canines
and a bike that could crush a bowling
ball
the lighter male slams his rival to the
ground
he survives the attack
but it's enough to shape the big male
in a Victory lap the lighter Grizzly
pushes the bigger male from the Winner's
Circle
there's only enough room for one Grizzly
on this Muscle Beach
thank you
further west the Nevada desert
only a few miles from the bright lights
of the Vegas Strip
and it's here in the shadows of Sin City
where one animal gambles with his life
the desert tortoise
on this Dusty Battleground the slowest
fights of the animal world unfold
they fight
they fence and when really provoked they
flip stuck like this tortoises can
overheat and die in the Desert Sun
this male is new to the neighborhood
he's built like a rock hard tank
but he has a soft spot for this female
[Music]
the problem is she's not impressed with
his romantic gestures
and he won't take no for an answer
[Music]
a few feet away a large resident male
hears the commotion
and curiosity gets the better of him
like a knight in Dusty armor the large
male comes to the rescue
he has no patience for the interloper
and his flagrant Behavior
outraged by such inexperienced rudeness
our local hero Bobs his head as a
challenge to the young upstart
[Music]
the smaller male is swept up in the
moment
[Music]
the resident male Won't Back Down
finally the rapid head Bobs catch the
intruder's attention
he's not happy about being interrupted
[Music]
the Intruder goes straight to the most
dangerous move in his repertoire
[Music]
the big male struggles to write himself
makes a run for it like only a tortoise
can
[Music]
in a blink of an eye
the Intruder takes off after the female
[Music]
the large male is left shell-shocked
it's not about to give up
he bolts after the scoundrel
[Music]
s
finally the resident male drives the
pests from the desert territory
and returns to his burrow to find the
female waiting for her prince charming
unlike our ninja tortoises the next
fighter will lay down his life in the
Battle For Love
[Music]
in battle over a female whitetail deer
can die of pure exhaustion
and if they're antlers entwine and can't
be wrestled free
it's a double death sentence
two Whitetail Bachelors lock and a
heated battle a female deer has come
between them
and she watches on as they show off in
front of her
they crouch on their front legs to lower
their center of gravity
in a violent tumble
to the advantage
neck Twisted the other male becomes a
punching bag for the herd
his neck could snap at any moment
antlers locked the losing Buck is
completely immobilized
starts to panic and tries to break free
if they can't unlock both contenders
will starve to death
the tactic has switched from fight to
flight
[Music]
but the struggle isn't over for this
buck
he's become his worst enemy
struggles to dislodge his leg
finally he breaks free
he'll live to fight another day
foreign
[Music]